Whoaa, you Dick.
Wayne?
Noah.
Mr. Dyck.
Darryl.
Hello, Noah.
Daniel.
Haven't seen ye in the age of a dog once. My
deepest sympathies that the love tree ye and
Lavina tried to plant together didn't take
root.
She's a special gal. I know that now more
than ever. How's she doing?
I suppose you've heard by now she was
attacked at a petting zoo.
No, I had not heard that.
A giant cock about yea, from behind even. It
would seem she was on the receiving end of a
good sized prick. Doctor said he'd never seen
a gash quite that size. The size of a fist.
And indeed that's all she had to suppress the
bleeding. Can you imagine a fist inside your
gash?
Tough week, don't they?
Oh, unfortunately, it doesn't end there. A
couple of days prior, my two young boys
caught the prickliest of the itches after
playing with a pile of pink insulation in the
barn. Would you believe on the same day my
daughter fell in the manure pile? I had two
in the pink and one in the stink.
What brings you by, Noah?
Wayne.
Your community has always used us right, and
hopefully you feel as though our community
has used you right as well. I need your help
at the Dyck farm once. Put it this way its
work only men can do. My two young boys
aren't quite up to the task yet.
Well, we got six strong hands. We can help.
I am blessed this day. For the Lord hath
given unto me three able men willing to help
me with a hand job.
What type of job is this, exactly?
Men banging.
Men pounding.
It's best I show you once.
I feel like we got our own work to do.
We'll be there, Noah.
Thanks unto ye, Wayne. Bring your tools.
By the way, my children have recently taken
to digging for buried treasures in the corn
fields. Their imagination hath no bounds at
this age. And though I've instructed them to halt.
Please, neighbors, let me know. Should
you see my children cornholing in the field.